and learn from coach Belichick,
what you supposed to do in
a situation like that.
It's really crazy for me because
when you look at this
play, don't look at the offense,
I want you to look in.
I want you to look in the end
zone and look at the
safeties. Look how far deep they
are in the end zone and
that's Harrison Smith. He's a
veteran player. He's an all pro
player.
You don't ever as a DB sit in
the end zone, you stand at
the goal line.
Because if they come in front of
you, and
They catch the ball as a
touchdown. We're taught.
Everybody needs to be at the
goal line. Don't be in the end
zone because all they have to do
is come in front of you,
catch the ball and it's a
touchdown.
Those are little simple things.
Little fundamentals and Zimmer
used to be one of the best
defensive coordinators around
all of NFL football. And all of
a sudden, you see things like
this
and it just doesn't make sense.
You got, what is this eight,
guys? Dropping in the end zone
and you can't stop one. That
means you can actually double
For
every receiver out on a football
field. Why is it
number 23 sitting in the end
zone? What does that gonna do
for you?
It's just crazy for me and then
teams wonder why coaches get
fired players, get cut because
it's those small things. It's
the fundamentals of football and
it's amazing to me
that that who's ever calling
that whether it's Zimmer or his
defensive coordinator. Like how
do you sit there and watch that
as a coach and C3 safeties
deep in the end zone. Why?
When you call a timeout, it's
just frustrating to me.
Right, that's a game. They have
to win and you made a great
point about the importance of
that kind of a loss as you as
you look towards the playoffs as
well. And this is a game
where Kirk Cousins is much, flak
is we have given him
Kirk Cousins. Played a really
good game watching this back.
Justin Jefferson had a huge
game. They ran the ball. Well,
they scored points. So that's
where it goes. Full circle.
Right back to Zimmer's defense
and let's give a little bit of
credit on the other side of the
thing to the Detroit Lions,
because the Detroit Lions are
a team that has struggled so
much.
Route this year, in terms of
losing, but they have been so
tough. In terms of competing
every game. It just seems like
they're in it right? Till the
end. They play so hard. They
want to win for their coach.
They love their coach. If you
saw that scene in the locker
room afterwards and they finally
got one done. I kind of
like what's happening with
Detroit's. It's a definite
rebuilt and they know that and
Jared golf's got to go from LA
to Detroit as he want to know.
But it does seem like there is
really some awesome
relationships developing between
their players and their
coach and their saying hard for
him.
Absolutely. I just saw.
I got to give a lot of crop
props to the Detroit Lions and
I was on the team that was one
in 15 and I think it was
the 11th week of the season.
When we played we end up beating
the Kansas City Chiefs and it
felt like it was the Super Bowl
and you know, to get up every
single day.
Get in there and lift weights
to work out, to practice meeting
study,
get the massages, cold tub, hot
tub, your whole and your whole
day, your process and to be able
to lose every single week.
It's disheartening. It's
Difficult to come to work.
I don't care. How many zeros
those texts have on them.
But at the end of the day, you
play this game because not only
do you want to get paid, you
want to win football games? And
I'm just so happy for Dan,
Campbell. He played. He's
passionate the lions are
prepared. Every time they come
out, they fighting their claw.
They don't have the most
talented guys, but they have
a group of guys that believe in
their coach. And if I'm if I'm
Detroit, I'm going to, I'm going
to jerk off and say, hey,
man, if you want to help us
become a better team,
you need to take a pay cut.
He needs to Redo his contract,
take up to take a pay cut and
maybe put it in incentives to
help Detroit Laurels. Lure.
Some more free agents over there
because that's what they
need. They need more Talent.
Yeah, it's interesting. That's
probably true as well. I agree
with you there. That's get to
number two on Turn the Page
Tuesday, which is the Cincinnati
Bengals. So
the Bangles are one of those
teams, they could beat anybody
and they can lose to anybody and
they got no problem doing
either one of them. Where is
that coming from for
the Cincinnati Bengals?
Well, we sit by each other,
every single Sunday and we
watched a Bengals in. It's just
kind of up and down. It's
a roller coaster ride. And what
you have to understand with
the Bengals is there are very
young team, but they're very
talented.
So, with young teams, you're
going to get inconsistent play,
and you just hope that it
doesn't come from
the quarterback. But you look at
Jamar Chase and how he's been
dropping the passes. Then he
looks great. Then he drops
other passes and you just look
at the inconsistency of their
team.
And yeah, you could blame a head
coach to a certain degree.
But this is a young team and
they're trying to figure out
how to win football games, and
the more experience, they get
the more opportunities and this
is Chase. Come on,
Jamar Chase. He's got to make
this play. I mean, you just
have to make make this play, you
know, your NFL wide
receiver Jack.
I mean, he's running
down the field. I mean, it's
just a
perfect throw from Joe Borough.
That could have been a
touchdown. Right? I mean, that
is just a perfect throw and this
is what we saw. In
the preseason. He had erased it
and now it's creeping back in.
And
that's where I agree with you in
terms of being a young team,
and I'm just looking at the most
drops around the league.
Deebo, Samuel has nine
Tyree, kill has nine. We saw
issues with that with him on
Sunday Night Football, but the
guy who was in third with
eight. There's only one guy with
eight drops in the league.
Is Jamar Chase? Oh, he is top
three in the entire NFL and
dropped passes this year.
So it's not just a preseason
thing.
It's something that's following
him at this point. And I think,
Joe burrow can pull him aside
and do certain things, but it
may just be a part of the
experience with Jamar. Chase.
The biggest thing I worry about
with the Bangles right now. Is
that pinky finger of jobber 0
because that is an important
finger. When you're trying to
grip a football. It's one of
the last ones that come off it
when you're trying to create
a spiral.
So I'm a little bit worried
about how blown up that pinky.
Finger was in terms of the
swelling on Joe burrow after he
took that hit.
Yeah, he looked like he was
really frustrated and a lot of
pain on the sideline. When he
was trying to throw, he threw
his helmet down yelling discuss.
So that's something
that I'm definitely
concerned about as well.
That's right. He's one tough
SOB, though. The fact that he
just keeps coming right back in
the game was like it was never
even a conversation. So here's
the play that he hurt that
finger on here it is. You can
kind of see kind of gets
grabbed right there from behind
pass. Rusher coming around and
just gets that right hand of
borough. He comes right back in
the game. You still throwing
it, but you could just tell the
discomfort and then when you
look at
it, the swelling was evident. So
tough situation right there.
Let's get to the LA Rams, the
Rams, finally, get a win after.
Tough skid. What page do you
think they need to turn though?
They're in LA.
What are you just got to keep
playing? You know, they got to
keep playing in the thing that
stood out to both of us when
you know, whenever we watch him
play. It's just the lack of
physicality and I started
thinking well, maybe it's
because they're
California their Dome team, or
maybe it's just the Personnel
that they have. But if you're if
you're getting beat up
upfront and Matthew Stafford,
he's dropping back and he has
zero confidence in offensive
line. And every time he drops
back, he feels like he's going
to
get hit, you're going to see a
different Matthew Stafford.
We'll see if this game, propels
them and Some confidence, but
I just don't see
the same Rams team on defense on
offense, flying around
that we saw earlier when they
played against the Chicago
Bears when we had that game
Jack.
Yeah, I don't think like just
beating Jacksonville fixes
everything, right? It's not a,
it's not a cure-all. It's not
for all the woes that they've
had this past month. It's just
a win and sometimes you just
desperately need a win and they
certainly did
and maybe that Springs them
forward but I don't think
beating Jacksonville fixes
everything. They've had
probably the plus side for them
has been that Odell Beckham jr.
Is starting to become something.
He started to become
a factor in this offense
and if Odell can start to pick
up some of that slack, right?
They have injuries at the wide
receiver position if they can
give Cooper. Cup another option
there. Another great option. On
the other side. You can just
check all the ego stuff at
the door and just
focus on football. He could
become a legitimate weapon for
them. And I think we're starting
to see that with obj,
there was this touchdown this
week, you know, and he can be
a weapon. I mean he has to
continue to build his
confidence in the system
and everything that you know
that they're trying to do. But
at the end of the day, they're
still going to have to, you
know have to worry about running
a football. They got to
run the football. Can't be all
Matthew Stafford. We've seen
this year.
It's all Matthew Stafford. What
happens to offense line breaks
down? They have some, they have
some breakdowns and then all of
a sudden, it's an interception,
or it's a sack, or what's
the strip sack of things like
that? If you
can't run the football,
if they can't run the football
and Sean McVeigh understands
his Matthew Stafford will be in
trouble.